hey 42 here every year Iceland gets
wider by two centimeters welcome to RIF
a cow with a name will produce 450 more
pints of milk a year than one without a
name in 2011 scientists re-measured
Norway's beaches islands and fjords
adding 11,000 miles to its coastline the
laborers who built the Great Wall of
China were fed on sauerkraut people who
pirate music also buy more music legally
than people who don't
pirate the human brain cannot feel Hey
Guinness isn't black it's very dark red
the closer a woman is to the equator
the more likely she is to give birth to
a girl nicotine increases the body's
metabolism of coffee and therefore can
reduce the impact of caffeine's effects
the average London pigeon has 1.6 feet
if you stood on the Martian equator at
noon it would feel like summer at your
feet and winter at your head you can
tell if someone is yawning from their
eyes alone the 25th of November 2012 was
the first day since 1960 that there was
no murder or manslaughter in New York
City in ancient Rome fathers had the
legal right to kill their children
German mothers-to-be are said to have
roast dinners not buns in their ovens
according to the main calendar the next
time the world is going to end is the
3rd of May 71-38
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2